we're in a parking lot with Rickey tang
and his car with a neat trick to extend
the range of your car key so the theory
is if I if I do this and I press on the
button and to work much longer so it
works right so let's try to go further
out this is one of those Clips where you
watch it and think well I'm gonna try
that immediately I still hear it and if
I heard who promoted like directly still
doesn't quite work so let's hope we can
take this I was kind of thinking has
this guy got some kind of magical cyborg
head so again nothing in this shredder
presence again because my chin it still
works incredibly Ricky's head can extend
the range of the remote from around 100
feet to over 260 feet here's this for
real
it still works a car door remote control
produces an electromagnetic wave which
is a radio wave a specific frequency and
that is what triggers the car to open
the door the reason the remote works
from someone farther away is that Ricky
points it at his head now your head is
mostly water in fact your brain is 75%
water water molecules have a positive
side and a negative side this means that
the electromagnetic waves can move that
charge up and down when you move a
charged particle you produce an
electromagnetic wave which is the same
frequency as the original signal this
means instead of one small
remote-control sending the signal it's
being beamed out of all of Ricky's head
this still works but as Ricky in danger
of frying his brain
although zapping electromagnetic waves
through your brain sounds dangerous
Ricky is going to be fine here because
the car remote only produces a small
amount of electromagnetic power and for
a very small amount of time so as long
as you have a car key and a head feel
free to try this one at home
it still works